[Applaus]
[Musik]
Philippinen und die Schweiz sind sehr
unterschiedlich so Geduld ist bei uns
wichtig
er braucht mehr Geduld
wir haben nicht speziell über die
Erziehung des Kindes gesprochen
[Musik]
es muss nicht mit einem Flickflack die
Treppe runterkommen
[Musik]
eine liebe das ist hin und weg
Aufregung in der tambur Bay auf den
Philippinen Familie Kunz geht auf große
Reise
schön hier bleiben nicht weggehen
es geht Richtung Hafen
eine Stunde dauert die Fahrt von Didi
Melisa und den beiden Töchtern
für die Familie ist es eine lange Sehnde
Reise
endlich wird Melisa ihre Eltern und ihre
Geschwister wiedersehen
doch der starke Seegang macht Tochter
Sarah zu schaffen
musst kannst du es halten nein es ist
okay
schau auf den Horizont
Familie Kunz war während der
corona-pandemie in der Schweiz erst vor
ein paar Wochen ist sie zurückgekehrt
Melisa sehnt sich nach ihrer Großfamilie
ich bin sehr glücklich sie nach drei
Jahren wieder zu sehen
ja das ist schön
weitere sechs Stunden Autofahrt liegen
vor ihnen
[Musik]
Melisa ist in einem kleinen abgelegenen
Dorf in den Bergen aufgewachsen
[Musik]
wir gehen jetzt zum Haus meiner Eltern
aber zuerst müssen wir ein Stück zu Fuß
gehen
für dich ich weiß du bist stark aber ich
kann dir helfen
wir sind mitten im Dschungel
ich bin so nervös
wir sind da
nicht der Carla begrüßt sie mit einer
segnungskiste
hallo
[Musik]
endlich kann Melisa ihre Mutter wieder
in die Arme schließen
auch ihr Vater ist überwältigt
hallo Mama
lange her
die Eltern sprechen nur bisaya kein
Englisch
vieles läuft über die Körpersprache
es ist fantastisch
unbeschreiblich endlich meine Eltern zu
treffen nach so vielen Jahren
es sind Freudentränen
es ist wunderschön
als meine Mutter dich zum ersten Mal sah
sagte sie sie sieht nett aus
mein Vater sagte wir haben eine andere
Kultur wir haben viele Ehefrauen in
Europa hat man nur eine Frau
im walme Steier schwelgen Stefanie und
Denis ulay in Erinnerungen vor neun
Jahren kam Dennis in die Schweiz
[Gelächter]
und hier
angefangen hat ihre Geschichte vor 11
Jahren
Stefanie war mit Mutter Annelies auf
Afrika-Reise
in der sandy beach Safari Lodge in
Sambia genossen Mutter und Tochter ihre
letzten Ferientage
dennis war Hotelmanager
als Stefanie zurück in der Schweiz war
meldete sich Dennis auf Facebook bei ihr
ich habe eine Freundin
zweimal reiste Stefanie zu Dennis mit
Schmetterlingen im Bauch
voll mit rosaroten
Schweiz und dann nehmen
wir schwanger geworden
[Gelächter]
vier Monate später heirateten die beiden
am Kariba See in Sambia
[Applaus]
aus Frau Albertin wurde Frau ullai ich
habe nicht eine Tochter verloren sondern
einen Sohn gewonnen
fünf Monate später kam Tochter Natascha
auf die Welt seitdem sind sie zu dritt
wieder mal
so zum
familienfamilie war
Jamal ist in Münchenbuchsee aufgewachsen
Mutter Gertrud und ihr Partner freuen
sich auf das erste Treffen mit Enkelkind
nur an
Auto
das Treffen findet in Bernstadt
Campingplatz
sie treffen sich bei Jamals Bruder
Harris und seinem Sohn Jaden
hallo
[Musik]
wo ist er
ist hier drin
[Musik]
ist
unglaublicher Familie vor der Uhr
und hier natürlich
sie und
Jaden gibt ein Cousin
Noam ist ein Leihmutter Baby und bekommt
spezielle Milch
das ist fantastisch die Milch ist sofort
bereit man muss nur einen Schnuller
aufsetzen
leer ist entsorgt man es
das einzige woran wir nicht gedacht
haben ist das ist sie in Europa nicht
gibt
also haben wir sie mitgebracht genug für
15 Tage
hoffen wir das reicht
vier fünf Wochen
[Musik]
die eine Reise in die Schweiz war
problemlos
natürlich
[Musik]
von den Großeltern erhält nur am ein
ganz spezielles Geschenk ein
persönliches Horoskop
er braucht keine Routine
nein er ist sehr kreativ
autonom perfekt
ein Naturbursche
[Musik]
und sie hat mir aber dann auf zitter
geschossen
[Musik]
auf den Philippinen stecken Elisa und
ihre Familie mitten in den
Vorbereitungen für das große Fest
ja das ist so bin ich aufgewachsen das
Essen kochen wir auf dem offenen Feuer
ja wir nennen das schmutzige Küche
alfreda
sie ist glücklich aber auch ein wenig
traurig
mit Didi leben wir halt sehr weit weg
wie fast überall auf der Welt versammeln
sich auch hier die Männer am Grill
das gehört zu der Philippine für jeden
Frosch machen sie so oben auf dem Grill
beseitig
und mir fällt das relativ leicht weil
ich das gesehen es fasziniert mich
[Musik]
mit neuen Geschwistern aufgewachsen
das einfache Leben hat sie geprägt das
will sie auch ihren Töchtern vermitteln
so bin ich aufgewachsen wir gingen
behutsam mit Ressourcen um wir waren
zufrieden mit dem was wir hatten
[Musik]
unterwegs
nach seiner Ankunft aus Sambia hat Denis
ulay schnell eine Arbeit gefunden
heute ist der Allrounder bei einem KMU
in misteyer
[Musik]
und das Holz ich hoffe ganz gut
so
[Applaus]
sauber hier sind Material
Dennis kennt alle hier
und alle kennen ihn
[Musik]
alles
gegeben
[Musik]
jemand zu Hause
hallo
Dennis und Steffi sind seit neun Jahren
verheiratet
Diskussionen über kulturelle
Unterschiede gibt es immer wieder mal
oh nein
ich gehe jetzt weg sagt sie okay bis
später und
hörten
und das hat verschiedene
eine Reise nach Sambia ist kostspielig
Natascha war als zweijährige dort
spielerisch versucht Dennis ihre
Erinnerungen an seine Heimat wach zu
halten
der Moment und dann ist
aber macht vorhin ja verstanden
es ist ein gutes Gefühl als Kind musste
ich immer selbstständig ins Bett gehen
meine Eltern sagten gehe jetzt schlafen
niemand zeigte mir Liebe und Fürsorge
das fehlte mir sehr
das werde ich besser machen
jeden Abend zeigen wir ihr das alles gut
ist und sie mit dem Gefühl dass wir alle
glücklich sind erwacht
das ist Geborgenheit
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Stefanie ist im Gemeinderat heute Abend
ist Versammlung
[Gelächter]
interessieren aber die Sprache ist
einfach noch ein bisschen ein Problem
[Musik]
auch Stefanies Mutter ist politisch
interessiert und mit dabei
Stefanie ist schulvorsteherin und gehört
keiner Partei an
Prozess Lernprozesse
[Musik]
auf den Philippinen ist alles bereit für
das große Fest
die Knochens nein er schneidet die
Schnüre
[Musik]
für das mehrtägige Fest gibt es vier
gute Gründe der Besuch von Familie Kunz
und drei Geburtstage die gefeiert werden
wollen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
ein so reichhaltiges Buffet ist für die
Großfamilie ein seltenes Vergnügen
der Fleisch ist sehr gut der war drei
Stunden im Feuer das ist so gut hier
aber ich kann das nicht richtig
schneiden
auf den Philippinen ist nur ein Fest mit
Karaoke ein richtiges Fest
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da müssen alle Gäste durch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich träume davon
im Sinn von so vielen
Traum wird wahr werden
[Musik]
und seine Frau Monika unterwegs zu ihrem
Herzensprojekt
überlegen
ihr Traum liegt mitten in der Natur auf
800 Quadratmetern
diese Anlage möchten die beiden
übernehmen und Massagen Yoga und
gesundes Essen anbieten Monika als
Managerin und de war als Koch ja
gebürtiger Glaner und die einheimische
Architektin Vera inspizieren die
15-Jährige Villa
das ist die beste Lage es ist für fremde
aber auch für Hotelgäste zugänglich
auch die war hat klare Vorstellungen
kommt eins ist gesundes Essen
und balinesische Küche
gemischt mit indonesischer Küche
Ueli könnte die Villa mit Luxus Zelten
aus seiner Firma erweitern er ist am
Projekt interessiert
die Zone
doch Architektin Vera hat Bedenken eine
Herausforderung eine große
Herausforderung
das Gelände des Resorts ist sehr steil
und müsste terrassiert werden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dieser steile Teil wird eine
Herausforderung wie schaffen wir mehr
Unterkünfte
die Schönheit ist da aber die
Herausforderung ist die Sicherung des
Geländes
wir müssen das mit den Behörden klären
die Unterkünfte wären sehr nah am Fluss
das könnte gefährlich sein wir müssen
schauen wo wir was bauen können
wir brauchen mindestens ein Jahr für die
Renovation der Anlage und für die
Konstruktion
wir müssen schauen wann wir beginnen
können mitten im Monsun sicher nicht all
das müssen wir berücksichtigen
inzwischen ist der Traum geplatzt der
Staat hat das Land zur unbebaubaren Zone
erklärt
Monika und Diva lassen sich nicht
entmutigen
sie brüten bereits über neuen Ideen
[Musik]
mit zwei
Wohnungen mit
es hat noch nicht geschneit
seit zwei Monaten sind Jamal und Roma
Väter des kleinen Normen noch haben die
beiden frei aber bald wird Roman wieder
als eiskunstlauf-coach tätig sein Jamal
will später wieder Teilzeit als
Schulleiter der isaakademie arbeiten
das vor der Kälte
er ist nicht erwacht
[Applaus]
mehr
doch ich sehe ihn den kleinen
und der Franzose Roma sind seit zehn
Jahren ein paar sie haben einen weiten
Weg hinter sich bis zur Erfüllung ihres
Kinderwunsches vergingen vier lange
Jahre jetzt dreht sich alles um Noah
er ist Kanadier wir müssen ihn
vorbereiten er wird unsere Kultur
mitbekommen aber er wird Kanadier sein
und ganz viel Ahornsirup trinken mit
ihrem leihmutter-baby wollen die beiden
auch anderen kinderlosen Paaren Mut
machen und ihre Familienplanung ist noch
nicht abgeschlossen
für die Zukunft fühle ich mich schon so
glücklich mit Jamal Noah was soll man
sich noch mehr wünschen
weiterhin Träume haben vielleicht ein
kleiner Bruder oder Schwester für noham
vielleicht
suchen
so glücklich
[Musik]
ich liebe dich weil du die Kinder
unterstützt Ihre Wünsche ihre Ausbildung
und mich auch
du bist immer an meiner Seite und
unterstützt mich darum liebe ich dich
auch die die und Melisa denken an die
Zukunft in der Stadt gibt es für ihre
Töchter bessere Schulen sie überlegen
hier ein weiteres Haus zu mieten
[Musik]
mal ein Haus gesehen hier und zum Mieten
war ich weiß nicht wie diese Straße oder
diese Straße habe keine Ahnung hier weiß
ich nicht genau so wir laufen morgen
werden
der Umzug ist eine große Entscheidung
die sie gemeinsam treffen wollen
das Haus in der tambur Bay wollen sie
behalten
schön
ich wünsche mir ein kleines Restaurant
cook
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ing Kochen und Essen sind wichtig
[Musik]
die Menschen essen dreimal am Tag es
wäre eine gute Einnahmequelle
[Applaus]
die Familie lebt von die dies Rente
falls Ihre Kinder der einst eine bessere
Schule besuchen wollen wäre ein zustub
von Melisa willkommen ausmachen
günstig
danke dass man
200 Franken
[Musik]
riecht es heute Abend ein wenig wie in
Sambia
die Liebe zum Essen aus ihrer Heimat
verbindet die Landsleute Linse und
Dennis
[Musik]
eine Nummer sicher
wirklich wie zu Hause
nicht ab
ja ja
ist ein typisches Gericht aus Sambia
besteht aus Zwiebeln Tomaten und dem
Gemüse
[Musik]
Steffi komm und versucht
afrikanisch
zu Herzen genommen
[Musik]
ich glaube es war vor einem Jahr als wir
Chima kochten
du kannst in die Küche und sagtest es
ist als ob viele Leute hier sind
wir sind so laut
da sind sich Stefanie und lindsis
Schweizer Mann einig
das Essen meine Muttersprache mit der
ich aufgewachsen bin das vermisse ich
und das Zusammensein mit Freunden aus
Sambia diese Offenheit das fehlt mir
manchmal
ist es nicht zu scharf
dass die Frau kocht und der Mann am
Tisch sitzt
immer am nageln das Essen ist nicht gut
mein Vater hatte vier Ehefrauen
ich habe gesehen wie er sie behandelte
das ist nicht okay
Dennis will es besser machen hier wo er
mit Steffi Natascha und einem ganzen
Dorf eine neue Heimat gefunden hat
für die Zukunft wünsche ich mir dass die
die gesund bleibt
und für die Kinder dass sie eine gute
Zukunft haben
[Musik]
als ehemaliger Bademeister ist die die
im Wasser in seinem Element die Familie
teilt diese Leidenschaft
[Musik]
es sind reine Glücksmomente
es ist fantastisch und unglaublich wie
Familienleben sein kann
miteinander
[Musik]
[Applaus]